hello everyone and welcome to a really
spectacular game from the final round of
the chestable Sunway sieges tournament
that's currently being played or rather
that was being played uh this is the
final round and it's kill alexenko
versus Hans moken Iman you know both of
them very well KIRO was a member of the
candidates tournament so it definitely
does not need any introduction and Hans
uh the man who can defeat everyone even
Magnus Carlsen In classical chess and
they are battling it out for the entire
tournament both of them have been
undefeated so far uh KIRO even started
with uh with seven wins then he got two
draws and now he's facing Hans here and
Hans started with some I believe five or
four wins and then he got some draws in
the win so basically Hans is down by
Half Point Hans needs a win with the
black pieces whereas uh kill will be
satisfied with a draw uh to win
everything so let's check it out it's
quite the game uh it's uh too
complicated for me too complicated I
believe for most people and as it would
seem too complicated for the players
themselves so let's check it out KIRO
with the white pieces opens with E4 we
have E5 Knight to F3 Knights the C6 and
the bishop the C4 the Italian game is on
the board Knight to F6 the two knights
of opening and now not Knights the G5
but the D3 the modern Bishops opening
and Bishop to C5 The Joker pianissimo Is
On The Board now we will have some pawn
moves with A4 D6 and now C3 and A5 with
castles by both players and now H3 and
H6 so this is all very standard stuff uh
nothing new being explored here Rook to
E1 and Bishop to E6 challenging the
bishop on C4 Knight to D2 and now Bishop
to A7 and here many moves were attempted
by white such as Bishop to B3 Rook D3
was tried Rook to B1 was tried Bishop
captures and E6 was tried even the move
played in the game Queen to B3 has been
played before putting pressure on the
bishop here and Hans just defends it
Queen to D7 and queen captures on B7 is
in the thread because that Queen will uh
get captured for example if Queen
captures you can First Trade here and
then Rook fb8 traps the queen uh or many
other ways you can trap it so after this
Knight to F1 are going for that E3
Square to counter the strong uh Bishop
on A7 Bishop captures and C for Queen
captures and now there is a game where
Knight to E7 was played here we have
Queen to E6 and it is now as of move 13
that we have a completely new game
so here akiro declines that the queen
trade goes Queen to B7 and we have
Bishop back to B6 uh or forward to B6
now everything is nicely defended you
don't have to worry uh and Knight three
to D2 uh maybe with some ideas of
knights the C4 going after the bishop
but also you can Retreat to B3 so your
queen doesn't get trapped with Knight to
A7 uh and that's exactly what happens
Knight to A7 Queen B3 and here Hans goes
for the queen trade captures captures
and Knight back to C6 so okay Queens
have been traded off uh and Akira is
looking very solid like I said he only
needs a draw to win the game and it's up
to Hans the try and mix it up to try and
push for more we have Knight to E3 going
for those D and F5 squares uh batan says
Nope the bishop thus seems uh does seem
to be less worse than the Knight here
and gives it up Bishop captures Bishop
captures an E3 and now Hans strikes in
the center with Pawn to 5 with F3
improving the center and now Rook 8 to
d8 the idea is not to just double up on
the D file or maybe via the the the E
file going to the D file so Bishop to F2
we have Rook F the E8 and now Rook 8 D1
we have B6 now defending the A5 Pawn so
the Knight on C6 can move uh Rook to D2
and now Rook to E6 we have Rook D to E2
uh going uh for the E file although I
don't really uh understand why uh this
just gives Hans the open D file I'm sure
there's a very good reason but like I
said it's a very very complicated game d
captures an E4 D captors and now hunts
just shift The Rook over to the open D
file now he controls it and uh Akira
will have to figure out how to take away
that control from Hans we have G3 Knight
to E8 uh and now uh Hans wants to bring
the move the Rook bring the Knight to E6
then bring the Knight to C4 and the
Knight on C4 will be a monster putting
pressure on that B2 Pawn so King G2 Rook
6 to D7 and now Bishop to E3 we have
Knights the D6 which also allows now
KIRO to take a sum of control uh of the
D file Rook to D1 and now Knight the C4
putting pressure on B to end the bishop
on E3 so Rook captures on D7 and while
Hans could trade this Knight for Bishop
uh he decides that the bishop will the
Knight will be stronger than the bishop
as it's a fairly close game and uh it's
okay it's an opposite sides of the board
so Bishop could be valuable but the
bishop isn't really doing all that much
on this diagonal plus it will be stuck
guarding the B2 Pawn so just we'll
capture some D7 Bishop to C1 and now
Knight to d8 okay uh Hans making a
little bit of progress here but nothing
uh nothing too much with knights the
d2kiro wants to trade as much as
possible Hans says not so quickly uh
Knight back to B3 and now Knight to E6
and the knight in Bishop uh are doing
their job but they're not really
spectacular this Knight can go cannot go
to C5 cannot go to D4 can't really go
anywhere uh you will have to shift it to
A1 and then maybe decide on maybe C2
square or maybe you're going to push the
beep on so Rook to D2 now if the Knight
moves KIRO is ready to go uh undergo
some further trading and now you cannot
move the Knight The Rook will be hanging
here so King f8 with Rook to D5 going
after the E5 pawn and the pawn to F6 now
we have King to F1 and King to E7
uh King to E2 now comes G5 grabbing some
space on the king side Bishop to E3 and
now finally Knight the C4 again putting
pressure on B2 and the bishop uh here
kirral trades Rook captures on D7 and
now King captures and D7 with Bishop
back to C1 guarding the B2 pawn and the
King to C6 now so are the knights here
better than the Knight and Bishop uh yes
they are but are they better enough to
actually win the game uh well that all
depends on the players on the player
wielding the the two knights so here
Knight the A1 by kiril Ponta H5 and now
comes the move that almost always wins
the game from White except uh uh in this
particular position uh here KIRO plays
Pawn to B4 and look at this a captures
on B4 C characters on B4 definitely
makes sense you want to create a pass
Pawn with A5 at some point Knight the D4
check now checking the king and
connecting with the F3 Pawn so it seems
that you you have to stay back to defend
the pawn but not really just Kink to D3
as the Knight and C4 is undefended now
Hans plays B5 the absolute top move uh
now if if a character's on B5 and
doesn't really do all that much you can
just play King captures the Knight will
be defended so here Pawn to F4 and this
is where the game really explodes this
is where the fun starts feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for Hans while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game as you always are
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is e captures an F4
this is the movie you have to find
leaving the Knight here stranded but if
the Knight is captured then uh Hans
would win the game uh in an incredible
fashion look at this if team captures
here then F captures on G3 and it seems
like you could maybe stop the pawn with
Bishop to E3 because now if Knight
captures King capture scene you can
reach the pawn but there's H4 and now it
doesn't matter what white plays really
completely it's the same there's G4 and
after age captures H3 and the pawn is
now Unstoppable so what you would have
to find after this e captures an F4 move
is G captures and now G4 H captors and
G4 and now H4 uh how do you stop the
h-phone now only F5 you have to free up
the F4 Square for the bishop because if
you go for Bishop to E3 now then it
doesn't work just H3 and after Bishop to
G1 there's Knight to F3 attacks the
bishop and guards the H2 Square that's
game so you would have to find this F5
move uh and then after H3 Bishop to F4
guarding the H2 Pawn then comes Knight
to F3 and the bishop will be lost for
example A5 you're just gonna play H2 now
uh KIRO would have to part with the
bishop and we would get this position
also the G4 Pawn is hanging now you have
to play G5 only move for white F
captures on G5 and this would be the
position that Hans would have gotten if
he uh played that so white does have
drawing chances he does have the past
Eep on the past F Pawn the past a pawn
but he would have to play an engine
perfect game uh in order to do so and
even then uh we cannot say for certain
but Hans almost immediately played G
captures on F4 and this allows KIRO just
to capture G captures on F4 now there is
no point in capturing you would just
lose the Knight Knight to F3 and now
Knight the C2 we have Knight the G1
going after the H3 Pawn now comes Knight
to E3 offering a trade of knights and
now Knight to B6 uh here interestingly
if you go after the H3 Pawn there's a
capture Sun B5 with check and uh now the
Knight is just hanging it's still okay
it's still better for black even after
captors and captures he will capture
this pawn and the black is just up so
many pawns even if captures here
captures here now the two pass pawns
here also this Pawn hanging uh it would
be white could struggle here to to get a
draw but not too much it would be a draw
so after Knights the E3 we have Knight
to B6 and now comes F captures on E5 we
have F captures on E5 and now Pawn to A5
attacking the Knight here Hans played
Knight to A4 and he was in this position
on move 50 that KIRO and Hans agreed to
a draw as there is nothing more to be
done uh there is there there are some
things to be done here but it is only
KIRO who can win this and it is not uh
uh he doesn't have to push for anything
he just needs to draw to win the
tournament and that's why uh they agreed
to a draw but just to give you an
example of what could happen and how
crazy the position is uh look at this
okay this Pawn is hanging so let's say
H4 and now how do you continue this with
hans's uh pieces let's say you go Knight
to F3 you want to win the spawn uh
you're already lost and you can't even
imagine why Knight to F5 and this Knight
is now trapped it's that simple uh
absolutely incredible uh for example 91
check you're just gonna play King to D2
you're gonna push the Knight back if
night the G20 Knight F3 check doesn't
really matter you're gonna play King to
E2 and now let's say King B7 you're
going to play King F2 and you can even
play Knight to F4 but now comes the
bishop captures on F4 e captures and E5
and there is no defense against the past
E Pawn and the past a pawn uh for
example King C8 You're Gonna Play E6
King to d8 now you're gonna play A6 and
after Knight B6 A7 and now doesn't
really matter King to E8 because all of
these squares are covered E7 and the
Knight cannot move the king cannot move
uh the king can easily gobble up all of
the pawns then pull the H Pawn to
Victory absolutely everything is winning
here so if the game had continued it
would be very hard for uh uh for for uh
Hans not to lose this but KIRO would not
be in any danger what what you would
have to find is King to B7 then you
would have to see after Knight to F5 did
you can play Knight the H3 and after
Knight the G7 going after the pawn now
C5 that's the way to play this
absolutely probably a stunning Knight
captures on h5c characters on B4 now
King C2 and now the only move that
doesn't lose for Hans B3 with check this
is how you prevent King to B3 King
captures on B3 now comes Knight the C5
check and even after Kingdom before you
can play Knight the D3 check connect
with the bishop uh and still King
captures on B5 Knight captures on C1
Knight to F6 you will not have to worry
about this spawn about this pawn and it
doesn't matter that black is up at night
uh White is still better here but in the
end it will be a draw so absolutely
incredible game uh Hans had a a great
opportunity here to play for the win if
he spotted after f for this G captures
an F4 idea but it's um it's incredible
that he played e captures an effort the
problem is I think that KIRO was the one
who was very low on time and Hans didn't
want to allow him to play on his time uh
that's why maybe he rushed it a little
bit but yeah both of them finish the
tournament undefeated but it is killed
Alex single who takes the win with seven
wins and three draws so absolutely
incredible stuff Kittle wins the
tournament he wins the chessable sound
we see just 2022 and Hans will emerge as
a 2700 once the rating list in January
is really released he will be some 2705
I believe so also a a a a a good
tournament for him but yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it and being
a big congratulations once again uh to
everyone who was able to solve this this
was a beautiful end game and I hope you
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank constantinos Lampard this Jeffrey
Clayman Miller Daniel Stone and David
grosskin for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day